[Music]
from Marvel Studios and Universal comes
the second movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that were doing an honest
trailer for because infinity Wars coming
out we've already done all the other MCU
movies and black panther isn't on
blu-ray yet
The Incredible Hulk meet Bruce Banner no
not the one people like who's that he
never played the Hulk did he no you know
the one I'm talking about the death to
smoochy guy there he is
edy Norton shines as the first Marvel
actor to show off how many crunches he
did for the part ah and he's bringing
his incredible range to a role that has
him act like he's on xanax I know a few
techniques could help you manage that
anger very effectively while off-camera
he's bringing his incredible ego to a
full rewrite of the script under the
fake name Edward Harrison do you want to
get Terrence Howard because that's how
you get Terrence Howard it'd join Bruce
for a story where he runs away from the
military runs away from the military and
runs away from the military again but
sometimes when his little Fitbit thing
he hits 200 he'll turn into the Hulk an
unstoppable rage monster that's actually
a huge danger to the entire planet the
economy of Brazil
and all of Harlem
yeesh I'm glad he flew up to not Planet
hawk it would mean earth left earth anis
to punch before Gweneth Paltrow took a
four-year hiatus and before Natalie
Portman took an indefinite absence
dumped us mutual dumping Liv Tyler
dropped off the face of the MCU without
so much as an Easter egg stand and smile
as the actress spends most of the movie
standing and smiling as she doesn't get
anything or even anyone to do I can't
get too excited you've always wanted to
see the Hulk match up against a villain
that could equal his powers well too bad
because he's fighting the skinny British
guy from Reservoir Dogs he's a decorated
veteran with zero personal connection to
Bruce Banner and zero threat to the Hall
but when he shoots himself full of
tainted Captain America juice he'll turn
into one of the most forgettable
monsters in the MCU the mixture could be
an abomination that was so bad he got
his ass kicked all the way the Batman V
Superman go back to the days before
Marvel had this whole universe thing on
autopilot where our nerd boners would
only get little taste of fanservice a
sequel was only lightly employed instead
of blatantly setting up five more movies
it put its post-credit scene before the
credits and photo shoot we were putting
a team together and didn't make a
billion dollars oh that's like Green
Lantern money
uh-uh no I know what it's like not about
expectations so strap in for this odd
sequel Requa reboot origin movie that's
better than we give it credit for
because whatever you think about the
film itself
it gave us Mark Ruffalo cool new job and
paved the way for Ed Norton to join Wes
Anderson's fancy boy Cinematic Universe
oh man I cannot wait for the Royal
Tenenbaums to fight Steve Zissou in
Budapest hotel infinity floor
okay Green Goblin nobody puts us out
Flash Thompson in this quirky hotel and
gets away with it story I am Jack's
departure due to creative differences
iggy pop like a Ross y'all got an Iron
Man suit that he's voicing and teenage
mutant ninja heroin addict
the disposable Hulk done this done
Esther in Guatemala yeah it's probably
not the first time a white guy got so
hammered in Brazil he woke up half-naked
in Guatemala
Spring Break 97 whoa don't sweat the
petty things and don't pet the sweaty
things oh hell no Karen keep your plant
as potato sell it to yourself I control
all the bats all the bats clouds are
just go she $50 fine and time served